Seit Mitte des Jahres läuft am Karlsruher
Institut für Technologie, dem KIT, ein gigantisches
Experiment. Hier geht es darum, endlich dem
Rätsel der Neutrino-Massen auf die Schliche
zu kommen - wir hatten darüber berichtet.
Bei diesem großen Rätsel-Raten könnte eine
bestimmte Formel helfen: die “Koides-Formel”
- Teilchenphysiker bezeichnen sie als besonders
“schön” und “elegant”! Aber halten
sich die Elementarteilchen an das, was in
der Formel-Welt als besonders gilt? Und was
kann Herr Koides’ Vorhersage zur Masse der
Neutrinos beitragen, damit wir die wohl mysteriösesten
Teilchen unseres Universums endlich verstehen?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
Science Videos. Abonniert den Kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr keins. Herzlich wilkommen
lieben Dank für diesen Themenvorschlag bei
Whats App! Neutrinos sind die häufigsten
Elementarteilchen überhaupt - sie formen
Galaxien und bewegen das Universum. Sie sind
elektrisch neutral, leicht und vor allem eines:
mysteriös. Oft werden sie auch als “Geisterteilchen
bezeichnet, denn sie rasen durch gewöhnliche
Materie wie Planeten, Bäume oder Häuser
einfach hindurch anstatt mit ihnen zu interagieren.
Forschungsteams weltweit stehen vor einem
großen Rätsel, wenn es um die Masse der
Neutrinos geht. Denn niemand konnte bislang
herausfinden, wie schwer die Teilchen wirklich
sind. 200 Forscherinnen und Forscher in Karlsruhe
sind an dem sogenannten KATRIN-Experiment
beteiligt und forschen hier an der “genauesten
Waage der Welt” oder dem “reinsten Vakuum
auf der Erde”. Wir hatten darüber berichtet.
Mit einem besseren Verständnis der Neutrinos
könnte man sich langfristig endlich auch
an die Grundfragen des Universums heranwagen:
Warum gibt es Etwas und warum gibt es nicht
einfach Nichts? Konkret also: Warum ist beim
Urknall ein Ungleichgewicht zwischen Materie
und Antimaterie entstanden? Zudem könnte
das KATRIN-Experiment auch dazu beitragen,
die sogenannte “Koides-Formel” zu verstehen.
Die wurde 1981 von einem Japaner aufgestellt
und stellt verschiedenen Arten von Elementarteilchen
in Zusammenhang. Und so sieht diese Formel
aus:
Konkret geht es um die Massen von Myon, Tauon
und Elektron. Elektronen kennt ihr sicher
aus dem Physik- und Chemieunterricht. Daneben
gibt es eben noch zwei Leptonen, die deutlich
schwerer sind: Myonen zum einen - diese sind
200 Mal schwerer als das Elektron und das
Tauon, das mit 3470 Elektronenmassen eine
deutlich größere Masse hat als das Proton.
Wenn ihr Euch jetzt die Formel noch einmal
anschaut, dann seht ihr auch das Ergebnis:
⅔. Ziemlich überraschend, dass hierbei
überhaupt so eine runde Zahl herauskommt.
Zudem liegt dieses Ergebnis genau in der Mitte
der möglichen Extremwerte. Heißt also: Das
Ergebnis wäre ⅓, WENN die Massen von Elektron,
Myon und Tauon identisch wären. Wäre die
Masse eines Teilchens deutlich schwerer als
das der anderen beiden, dann würde das Ergebnis
1 lauten. Doch wo genau liegt der Zusammenhang
zwischen diesen drei Elementarteilchen? Oder
anders gefragt: Gibt es überhaupt einen Zusammenhang?
Oder aber ist das alles nicht mehr als ein
numerischer Zufall? Weiterhin ist auch die
Frage offen, warum Elementarteilchen eben
die Masse haben, die sie haben! Immer noch
sind Forschungsteams nicht in der Lage, die
Masse der Teilchen aus einer Theorie zu bestimmen
- als theoretisch herzuleiten. Den exakten
Wert der Masse erhält man nur durch eine
Messung. Der Higgs-Mechanismus wurde zwar
durch den Nachweis des Higgs-Bosons im Jahr
2012 belegt. Doch auch er kann lediglich beschreiben,
wie Teilchen zu ihrer Masse kommen nicht wie
groß sie ist. Das alles zeigt mal wieder
die Grenzen des Standardmodells der Teilchenphysik
auf. Natürlich ist es auch super erfolgreich,
doch Experimente konnten weiterführende Hypothesen
- wie etwa die der “Supersymmetrie” dass
es eine Symetrie zwische Teilchen gibt und
sie ineinader umwandelbar sind - bislang noch
nicht bestätigen. Die Formel von Herrn Koides
jedenfalls zeigt einen mathematischen Zusammenhang
zwischen physikalischen Größen. Doch die
große Frage lautet, ob deswegen auf jeden
Fall auch ein physikalischer Zusammenhang
bestehen muss. Fraglich, ob die Natur und
das Universum sich von solchen schönen, beeindruckenden
und eleganten Resultaten beeindrucken lässt.
Denn warum sollte eine Beschreibung der Natur
zwingend auch “schön” sein? Auf der anderen
Seite ist natürlich aber auch vorstellbar,
dass diese elegante Formel auf einen uns noch
unbekannten Mechanismus hindeutet. Ganz konkret
ausgedrückt: auf Naturgesetze, die noch nicht
entdeckt worden. Ausgeschlossen ist es keinesfalls,
dass diese als ästhetisch gefeierte Formel
somit mal zur Weltformel aufsteigen könnte.
. Wenn ihr garantiert kein Video bei Clixoom
verpassen wollt zu diesem und allen anderen
Themen dann abonniert Clixoom auf englisch
hier, einfach draufklicken, denn da gibt es
auch Videopremieren, wie das Exklusiv-Interview
mit dem Havard-Professor Loeb. Hier geht es
weiter mit “Sensation at the CERN: A Portal
to a new kind of physics has been opened!”
Wir sehen uns auf dem englische Kanal von
Clixoom Stay tuned and see you soon!